aber unter jedem einer video seht ihr
unter jedem einer videos steht diese
frage mindestens 20 mal etwas kaputt ist
willkommen beim neuen video
ja es ist gerade einfach nur 43 und ich
habe strabag ein video zu drehen
deswegen hab ich mir nach decker setzt
sich nach unten machen video ich will
meinen eltern gar nicht stören oder mein
bruder
aber wir machen jetzt ein video oder ich
mache ein video für euch ich hoffe dass
es cool und das freut euch ist das
scheißegal wir fangen jetzt direkt an
und zwar habe ich mir wieder kranke
fragen von euch rausgesucht die echt
unter meinem letzten fragen und
antworten video richtig für
diskussionsstoff gesorgt haben
deswegen wesen wir uns jetzt mal schön
durch beantworten die und ich hoffe ihr
könnt damit was an tragen wenn ja dann
hat spaß jetzt und los schon mal fetten
daumen nach oben da weil ich glaube
heute sind mal richtig krass viele likes
drin ist auch eigentlicher wir fangen
und zwar mit der ersten frage dich hat
auch sogar 37 leicht tut mir auch mega
light dass da noch keine weiteren
informationen kamen aber was ist mit
einem fanshop ich wollte das muss ich
cool sorry ich wollte das eigentlich
schon vor 12 monaten rausgeballert haben
aber irgendwie gab es ein paar
komplikationen ich hoffe das kommt jetzt
allerdings ins rollen müsste es
eigentlich weil ich habe auch coole
ideen was man was man so machen kann
ich habe einfach mal in die kommentare 1
kommentar schreibt beschreibt was sorry
es ist schon spät ich habe einfach mal
in den kommentaren kommentar geschrieben
like diesen kommentar wenn du wirklich
bock auf diesen fällen show passt ist
interessiert mich gerade irgendwie und
deswegen wenn ihr da halt interesse
daran habt dann laster auf jeden fall
mein like da bei ihrem kommentar nächste
frage die leute es ist an der zeit da
muss ich diese frage wirklich mal in ein
video beantworten ich dachte das wird
nicht nötig sein ich habe schon unter
sämtliche videos habe ich schon die
antwort auf diese frage geben aber unter
jedem einer video seht ihr unter jedem
einer videos steht diese frage
mindestens 20 mal und zwar fragt hier
irgendeinen space frames wie heißt der
intro song leute ich weiß gar nicht ob
ihr darauf zugefahren könnt weil ich hab
halt weil ich partner bei bestimmten
netzwerk bin habe ich ein zugriff auf so
eine audio bibliothek und da ist dieses
krasse blieb drin das heißt get lost und
ist von niklas gustavs
mit 2 v und zwei es glaube ich keine
ahnung voll komisch geschrieben
ich hoffe ihr könnt damit was anfangen
und die last mit dieser frage jetzt in
ruhe wenn ich dann bombardiert nicht
gern weiter damit ich habe sie jetzt
einmal beantwortet wird es dann glaube
ich nicht mehr tun
nächste frage leonie fragt wieso sind
deine titel so klick ganz ehrlich das
ist jetzt unter diesem video
ich finde dass ich denke mir wirklich
immer so alles was im video vorkommt so
kann man auch den titel nennen ich mein
ich will ja auch gerne leute mit meinen
videos erreichen und da kann man auch
den titel möglichst sage ich mal ja
attraktiv gestalten so dass leute sich
das anschauen weil ich meine alles was
ich meinen titel schreibe ich habe noch
nie was in meinen titel geschrieben wo
es dann halt nicht im video darum ging
und zwar das war jetzt unter meinem
letzten fragen antworte video das hieß
mein schönes beziehungsende da war ganz
einfach eine frage hattest du schon mal
ein schlimmes beziehungsende und ich
habe beantwortet ob ich schon mal ein
schlimmes beziehungsende hatte was halt
vielleicht der fall war früher mal was
daran jetzt ein problem ist mir
scheißegal sagt dass ich klicke bemüht
mich und nächste frage und zwar würdest
du mal eine kette von dir verlosen warum
eigentlich nicht
also ich habe so eine rote kappe setze
ich ihn nicht mehr auf die habe ich
schon so lange ich bin mal kurz und foto
damit ein wenn ihr wollt dass sich die
man verlor sie dann verlor sich die
jetzt schreibt in die kommentare warum
ihr die haben schreibt was cooles nico
mendt halle schreibt in die kommentare
was glaubt ihr wie viele abonnenten habe
ich in genau heute in zwei wochen
alex das ist richtig gut bin ich bin
voll kreativ auf jeden fall da gucke ich
halt genau in zwei wochen nach um genau
diese uhrzeit wie viele abonnenten ich
habe und der der halt weg diese zahl
erwarten hat oder der die zahl ungefähr
oder in fast erraten hat kriegt dann
halt ich hab das geld oder man also
schreibt ihnen kommentare was glaubt ihr
wie viele abonnenten habe ich heute
genau jetzt zu dem zeitpunkt in zwei
wochen also ich glaube es ist gerade
dienstag
um 18 uhr genau heute in zwei wochen
dienstag 18 uhr das macht meine nächste
frage die nächste frage kommen von
benjamin irgendwas um 12 uhr herr alex
ich habe gerade schluss mit meiner
ersten freundin das macht mich mega
traurig und ich kann an nichts anderes
mehr denken hast du vielleicht ein tipp
für mich ja lieber benjamin ich werde
mich alex wenn ich keinen tipp für dich
hätte deswegen das ist also ich kann
glaube ich so verstehen wie du dich
vielleicht gerade fühlen mag ich es
jetzt einfach mal daraus das ist deine
erste freundin ist dass du eventuell
noch nicht 18 bis 15 oder 16 keine
ahnung
und ich kann nicht wirklich verstehen
also das ist halt so wenn man das erste
mal mit seiner freunde auseinander ist
dann ist das schon scheiße also vor
allem weil man dieses gefühl noch gar
nicht kennt sag ich mal so plötzlich
diese person nicht mehr zu haben
allerdings kann ich dir auch versprechen
in einem monat vielleicht auch essen
zwei monaten sieht das schon wieder
heftig anders aus und das ist halt ganz
normal dass man wenn man vielleicht
seine erste freundin hat dass es nicht
ewig hält so ist halt leider so was
heißt leider weil mir eigentlich
überhaupt nicht leider auf jeden fall
gibt's da wahrscheinlich auch wieder so
20.000 studien die das belegen
ich kann dir nur sagen du wirst mit 17
oder 18 oder noch wirklich eine finden
wo du dir nochmal viel sicherer bist als
mit der vielleicht deswegen macht er
keinen kopf das wird wieder glaubt
beziehungs berater alex nicht schlecht
gemacht tricks dankeschön
übrigens ich kann das video jetzt
theoretisch auch wieder nennen
freundinnen macht schluss umgang fragen
und antworten ich verstehe nicht wo das
problem ist ich meine ich habe doch
gerade auch diese frage beantwortet
genauso gut kann ich es nennen wehr job
aber dann nämlich doch lieber freunde
macht schluss ich meine ich weiß ganz
genau dass lincoln dieser titel besser
gefällt wenn es blöd nur dann hättet
mich jetzt kein problem alles gut ich
kann darüber stehen ja die liebe gefragt
würdest du für 500 euro ein freund auf
den mund küssen mit 500 euro nicht
müsstest du mir 5
was heißt ganz ehrlich ich bin nicht
schwul ich habe eine freundin 500 euro
haben oder nichthaben alter okay ich
will das auch nichts falsches sagen
nicht dass er nie mehr
es kommt eh wenn ich jetzt sagen würde
ja klar will ich mache nicht mein 500
euro kommt wieder 100 mal in die
kommentare
du bist schwul du bist du schwul
deswegen nein nein ich mache jetzt auf
jeden fall schon nach 2 uhr ich bin auch
nur müde keine ahnung warum ich muss
morgen um 9 uhr aufstehen mal sehen ob
ich meine friseuse bin wahrscheinlich
schon so ist das halt bei mir über ich
wahrscheinlich auch kein arm
ansonsten wassers mit dem video wenn es
euch gefallen hatte last auf jeden fall
jetzt meinen daumen nach oben da mal
sehen wieviele likes drin sind morgen
gehts weiter mit dem nächsten video das
drückte auf keinen fall verpassen check
das auf jeden fall ab dass wir megabits
ich denke ich deswegen morgen 18 uhr
auch einschalten snapshot instagram als
angewendet aber nicht vergessen
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
vorträge checke meine anderen videos
noch auf alles in der video beschreibung
verlinkt habe euch lieb